[Music]
it's been way too long the smartest
brick and Martius morty in the universe
are bad things are pretty much the same
[Music]
[Applause]
over the years the show's become more
and more cinematic you look at that
first season you got very locked down
cameras you know very simple mostly
people just talking to each other we've
now tripled our volume we pushed over
900 assets for this one episode which in
animation terms is not something that is
normally done crowds crowd scenes are
just impossible to animate a lot of
people worked really hard to achieve
that sometimes the pain is worth the
effort
this season we're doing lots of crazy
camera moves there's this shot you know
coming up in one of the episodes it's
this huge you know Game of Thrones big
armies and stuff all marching toward I'm
not gonna give too much away
but when I read the script I was a
little worried the end result always
comes through and always looks amazing
wicked Morty is a vector-based puppet
show each of the characters here are
broken up into million little pieces and
that means each individual piece of a
character that you're seeing is
something that's been drawn and then as
you animate you're popping from symbol
to symbol to animate quadrupeds you know
something with four limbs you have to be
constantly kind of accounting for every
aspect of an animal's movement and that
was that was a particular challenge
there's a dragon and there's a cat that
puppet that dragon puppet has to be good
like the neck has to be able to express
things go in and out in 3d depth you
need it to have weight you don't want to
entering a scene with casual and
you can get tricky and those are all
decisions that need to be made quickly
because of the pace of production it
wouldn't be the show if we weren't you
know working straight up to the deadline
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new Rick and Morty season
4 trailer video for episode 6 a couple
of the episodes from the rest of the
season in a breakdown of all the episode
titles and Easter eggs I'll be doing
weekly videos for the episodes just like
I normally would so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the episodes because the seasons back
we'll do Rick and Morty merch giveaways
week to week all you have to do to enter
that it'd just be a subscriber and leave
your favorite moment from the first tab
of the season on the video so we'll
start with all the episode titles and
Easter eggs then I'll talk about the
other footage because they also dropped
a trailer just to explain why it takes
so long to make Rick and Morty episodes
there was even a special Adult Swim
podcast that they did earlier last year
where they kind of talked about the same
thing why it takes so long to animate
Rick and Morty compared to other
animated series some of you probably
recognize some of the Easter eggs and
the titles here some of them are a
little bit easier to pick out than
others first off there's a very obvious
terminator reference with the way they
do these titles rick and morty trays a
lot of pop-culture references from the
80s so no surprise that they use
terminator as the theme of this big
title reveal trailer
but Episode six is titled never Ricky
Morty that's going to be this Sunday
that's a reference to the neverending
story most of you have probably seen
that or at least seen part of it it's
also a callback to Rick's rant at the
end of the first episode in his rant at
the end of season 3 episode 1 where he
started talking about Rick and Morty
forever 100 years Rick and Morty the
Szechwan rant was a little bit different
but with the 70 episode renewal if they
do 10 episodes per season that'll take
them to ten seasons of Rick and Morty
there's no official synopsis for episode
six yet but episode 7 is titled
primordius which is a reference to
prometheus alien the Xenomorphs you see
in walking around in the trailers with
these face huggers on the synopsis just
reads get off my face bro obviously an
alien reference you may remember a
couple years ago Rick and Morty actually
did a trailer video that was a crossover
with the Alien franchise toxicity due to
all the drugs and alcohol swirling about
in my system well Rick you know they say
don't do drugs but I think this might be
a case for and alcohol Morty yeah and
alcohol so I'm gonna get a memo to all
the characters in those Alien movies
stats yeah no kiddin you know I never
thought I'd say this but thank God you
drink all those drugs and alcohol you
know you don't drink drugs whatever I
don't know some of the footage from the
trailer is a little bit easier to pair
with some of these episode titles like
the joke about them doing the super long
anime suit up montage which seems like
it's a reference to ronin warriors where
they're fighting the race that's been
taken over by these facehuggers episode
eight is titled the vat of acid episode
the synopsis just reads the one with the
vat of acid bro this is probably a
reference to that scene in the trailer
where Rick is talking to Morty is saying
if anything goes wrong jump into the
same vat of acid that I do there's also
this scene where they're walking around
with these vats that look like green
portal fluid that could be the acid
episode they also posted this preview
image with them trying to trade some
crystals for something else this deal
sounds like it's going down inside this
room with all the vats of acid episode 9
is titled children of Morty the synopsis
just reads miracle of life bro whole
family in this one bro the title is a
reference to the movie children of men
that was a movie where the human race
had stopped reproducing in his
apocalyptic future then all of a sudden
a miracle baby is conceived making the
woman the last pregnant woman on the
planet she and the baby become these
mythical figures that the government
then tries to hunt down and capture you
could also call that theme a callback to
raising gazorpazorp or morty tries to
deal with becoming a father and raising
a child there's even a whole battalion
of gazorpazorp over here on the left and
this giant army in the trailer then
season 4 episode 10 the finale is titled
star Mort Rick turn of the Jerry the
synopsis just reads parenting is crazy
bro straight-up disappearing in this one
obviously that's a reference to Star
Wars Return of the Jedi you have a whole
bunch of Rick's chasing Morty here and
it looks like Jerry is flying around the
tubes inside the Citadel so that might
be their big evil Morty's Citadel
episode because Dan Harmon and Justin
roiland said there supposed to be some
epic season 5 teaser in a post-credits
scene during one of these episodes and
without seeing any more footage I think
it's safe to assume that it's supposed
to be the finale that's usually where
you put the tag if it's not gonna be a
mr. poopy butthole scene again most
likely some sort of evil Morty scene if
it's supposed to push them into season 5
since he's the biggest ongoing
antagonist of the series if they're
supposed to have a big Citadel episode
you also have a lot of Tammy and maybe
Phoenix person stuff happening there's
no Phoenix person in the season 4
trailer that we saw but if Tammy is
there then it means that Phoenix person
is somewhere nearby and if we're talking
about Star Wars references in the finale
you have the very obvious Star Wars
reference with Tammy fighting with what
look like lightsabers not really sure
why they're fighting there's a giant
wasteland behind them so it seems like
there's this giant battle going on
around them but summer really hasn't
referenced Tammy since the events of the
season 2 finale at that wedding when
everything went crazy maybe it has
something to do with snuffles fighting
this giant cat and their mechs in the
background I know a lot of you are
wondering if this is the same cat from
the first half of season 4 I'm not
assuming it's the same cap but they
might have some funny callback to that
episode where they appeared into its
mind and saw something that was so
terrible it just made them throw up so
the post-credits scene could either be
some evil Morty scene it could be
something with Tammy Phoenix person it
could even be some unholy alliance
between the Citadel and the Galactic
government or the remnants or whatever's
left the Tammy's trying to take control
of as for what's going on with season 5
obviously we have the 70 episode
renewals so there's no need to worry
about season 5 season 6 season 7 is just
a quest
of how they're gonna break the episodes
up so given the way they broke season
four into two halves
what they might do is just continue
doing the same thing so later this year
around November or October we get the
first half of season five then maybe
around this time next year we get the
second half of season five all the
interviews that they've done in the last
year or so make it sound like they've
fixed a lot of their delays inside the
writers room but the animation still
takes forever as they say during that
behind the scenes trailer just because
it's so complex so if they continue to
break each season up into two halves
that's probably why just to give them a
little more buffer and time to complete
the animation so at least they'll be a
little more predictable next year we
want to wait through January and
February just wondering why they haven't
talked about new episodes for the second
half of season five where are the
episodes well they're probably gonna
come sometime in the spring everyone
post all your predictions in the
comments below if there any special Rick
and Morty bonus videos that you want me
to do just let me know in the comments
but the videos that I post for episodes
will typically post Monday mornings so
as long as you have alerts enabled for
my channel you should see those when I
post them sometimes they'll drop extra
footage during the week so they drop any
more brand-new footage then I'll try to
do a new trailer video for that too
but everyone click here for all my Rick
and Morty's season 4 episodes and click
here for the Avatar The Last Airbender
Netflix teaser trailer thank you so much
for watching everyone stays safe I'll
see you guys tonight